[Musik]
besatzung maximal 17 personen
gesamtmasse bis sechseinhalb tonnen
motorleistung 173 ps
höchstgeschwindigkeit am land 50 km h
höchstgeschwindigkeit im wasser 3km h
haupteinsatzgebiet transportaufgaben in
unwegsamen gelände und wie das ganze als
in action aus schauen sie dann
[Musik]
für eine sportart im kern von geht es
mit 145 stundenkilometer kopf voraus den
eiskanal herunter und nur mit sturzhelm
und einem rennanzug und ja diese nicht
gebannt und deswegen ist es finden heute
erst einmal neue form
[Musik]
ja zweimal da oben und den hut nimmt und
es ist wahnsinn wie woomera oben ist und
ja was da viel kraft dahinter steckt
wenn man gas gibt dann spürt man einfach
echt getroffen was das gerät hat und es
ist spannend
[Musik]
insbesondere dann hätten seine zwei
kabinen die gelenke mit ihr verbunden
sind und natürlich der kettenantrieb
beteiligen gerät ermöglicht hoch zu sein
[Musik]
das ist der prototyp der hund vom
österreichischen bundesheer
er wurde ausgebuht der stadt und die
daraus gewonnenen erfahrungen die werden
jetzt im neuen gerätschaften mit
einfließen
[Musik]